[Music]
on this Thursday night the Prime
Minister pushes back on pressure for a
prisoner swap I deeply disagree with
that Justin Trudeau rejects calls to
release mung Wong Jo in hopes it would
make China release the to Michaels but
it is not just the two Michaels who are
at question here it is every Canadian
who travels to China or anywhere else
overseas québec's quiet change to its
Kovach 19 communication strategy critics
call it incomprehensible the pandemics
indirect impact on kids health what
doctors want parents to know and tainted
grapes don't mean sour grapes you just
have to get creative
Canadian wineries bottle up innovation
born out of a crisis
[Music]
mobile national with donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
the Prime Minister is rejecting mounting
pressure to release top Chinese telecom
executive mung Wong Jo in hopes it would
prompt China to let Michael spar and
Michael Kovarik come home to Canada
Justin Trudeau says randomly arresting
Canadians doesn't give China leverage
over the Government of Canada he is
rejecting the advice of 19 high-profile
Canadians who wrote a letter to him
imploring him to release mung Wong Jo
the signatories include a former Supreme
Court justice former liberal and
conservative foreign affairs ministers a
former justice minister a former NDP
leader and former diplomats it says the
Minister of Justice has the legal
authority to act now in the extradition
process of mung Wong Jo and it says we
contend the time has passed jus for the
minister to do just that to end the mung
proceeding and to bring the two
Michael's home it says not only are
their lives at stake Canada's foreign
policy is also being held hostage
but Justin Trudeau said today he does
not agree with them and will not let
China get away with what he calls
hostage diplomacy David akin is with me
from Ottawa David what exactly did the
Prime Minister say well Trudeau was
clearly aware of the pedigree of the
group that signed that letter but he was
having none of their arguments I respect
the distinguished Canadians who put
forward that letter but I deeply
disagree with them now as for the
Chinese they took note of the status of
those signatories to remember this was
an extraordinary letter and so on
Wednesday the spokesman for China's
foreign ministry while he took the hint
and he said the situation of the two
Canadians could be quote resolved if
Canada dropped the extradition
proceeding against mom so that is the
first time a senior China stat Chinese
official has essentially admitted that
China is holding the two Michels hostage
and would barter them for mungs release
now well Trudeau said that he empathizes
with the families of the two Michels and
he understands their suffering but as
Prime Minister Trudeau said he must
consider some broader issues the bigger
question is whether or not
we want China or other countries to get
the message that all they have to do to
get leverage over the Canadian
government is randomly arrest a couple
of Canadians that not only puts
Canadians in difficulty now but puts
them in difficulty and in danger in the
coming years now Trudeau's said his
government intends to make it quote
crystal clear that Canada has an
independent court system and that those
legal processes will proceed free of any
political pressure including from
foreign governments donna david aiken in
ottawa thanks now to the pandemic the
number of confirmed cases around the
world is fast approaching ten million
and the number of deaths is nearing half
a million the united states has by far
the most cases and the most deaths right
now but some countries that had
controlled their outbreaks are again
seeing an uptick in numbers australia
once nearly free of the new corona virus
is again ramping up its response there
were 37 new cases there today
australia's biggest one-day spike since
april the country now has more than 7500
known cases and in victoria australia's
hardest hit state a testing blitz is
underway ambulances and mobile test
centers are set up in residential areas
the goal is to do 100,000 tests in ten
days the army is being deployed to go
door-to-door to encourage people to get
tested india recorded more than 16,000
new cases of koban 19 and 24 hours
that's the highest single day increase
there there are now more than 480 1000
cases in India the fourth highest in the
world because of limited testing it's
believed the real number is likely much
higher and in the u.s. concern keeps
growing as cases of kovat 19 are rising
in at least 29 states among the hardest
hit are Texas California and Florida the
US also marked a grim milestone
reporting over 45,000 new cases on
Wednesday a record for a single day more
than 2.4 million people are now known
havock Ovid 19 in the US that is only
the people who have been tested
according to new estimates from the
Centers for Disease Control the real
number could be ten times higher
Jennifer Johnson reports after months of
downplaying COBIT 19 Texas is setting
disturbing records 5500 new cases in one
day the governor who last week said
there was no reason to be alarmed
has announced a temporary pause in any
additional reopening
we're at that stage now where if you do
not need to go out and go to work or I
have to go to the store or engage in
some other activity the best thing that
you can do is to just stay at home
in early May US President Donald Trump
publicly praised Greg Abbott as the
governor who reopened restaurants retail
stores malls and movie theaters
it's very special governor he's done a
phenomenal job
now intensive care beds in Houston are
at near capacity already today we
transferred a patient in and immediately
we had to intubate her she's in her
forties business owners are frustrated
too I don't know how many people have to
get sick and die so I can stay in
business new records are also being set
in California and Florida a mask mandate
creating a fiery debate in Palm Beach
County you literally cannot mandate
somebody to wear a mask knowing that
that mask is killing people but medical
experts strongly recommend wearing masks
as an added level of protection along
with physical distancing in these new
hot spots the greatest increase in Nuuk
ovid 19 cases is among 18 to 34 year
olds they're not going down a level
going out with mass and social
distancing they're going back to the way
they were they said you know it's not
going to affect me dramatically I can't
handle the White House officials not too
concerned about the surge we just have
to live with that that's I think part of
the story of the declining impact of the
virus but government health officials
call the trend disturbing and now
predict cope in 19 will kill 180,000
Americans by October Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington a new analysis
confirms what we know about the toll
Kovan 19 has taken on people in
long-term care homes in Canada and
reveals how
that Canada's record is on that compared
to other countries the Canadian
Institute for health information says as
of May 25th long-term care residents
made up 81 percent of all reported Kovac
19 deaths in Canada and that's nearly
double the average in 16 other developed
nations there are big differences
between the provinces and territories
long-term care deaths accounted for 97%
of CO bed 19 deaths in Nova Scotia in
Quebec Ontario and Alberta it was more
than 70% today the numbers in Quebec
have stabilized the province reported
seven more people have died of koban 19
it's the ninth day in a row there have
been fewer than 10 deaths and it's the
last time the public will get a daily
update on the numbers in that province
Quebec has decided to release data every
week instead of every day that has
surprised a lot of people Mike Armstrong
explains québec's new strategy there's
an old trick governments employ when
they don't want news covered they
release it on a Friday afternoon or a
holiday well as Quebecers were
celebrating the fête nationale wednesday
the provinces health ministry slid a
line into its daily kovat 19 update
there would no longer be daily updates
going forward it will be on a weekly
basis every Thursday opposition
politicians were quick to pounce the
Bucks québécois leader demanding an
explanation
while the Liberal leader called it
totally incomprehensible mr. Bolger
defending the decision fell to the
Director of Public Health Horacio arruda
argues the daily numbers have fallen to
the point publishing them doesn't make
sense as there is less and less cases
and less of less people dying from it
the stability of the data when we
publish every day is not as good as if
we look at within a week
now critics argue the move is a blow to
transparency there are other provinces
in Canada in a much better situation
still giving daily updates even if as is
the case of Pei they haven't had a new
case in close to two months Quebec added
142 new cases Thursday when you do daily
data releases you keep people aware and
I think you send out a queue that they
need to maintain vigilance there are
those who argue the opposite putting out
numbers every day can overload the
public it almost becomes white noise
that ends up being ignored if you get
all the small numbers all the time
people actually won't notice them
anymore they won't pay attention and
they will have this the the false
impression that everything is under
control and they can forget about that
virus a lot of experts say they don't
watch the daily numbers closely that
they look at trend lines fluctuations up
and down actually distract from what's
happening overall my eyes automatically
go to the trend line of what's been
happening over the last seven days and
that's much more informative I find in
your daily numbers the vex health
departments as it will still be watching
the numbers daily if there's a flare-up
it could and would go back to daily
updates my carbs are global news
Montreal the driver of a car involved in
a deadly crash in Brampton Ontario has
now been charged Global News has
confirmed 20 year-old Brady Robertson is
facing several charges including
dangerous operation causing death in the
fatal collision last week he's scheduled
to appear in court next month
[Music]
despite the pain and heartache we feel
we were blessed to have had these
beautiful souls in our life the crash
killed Karolina chase Ulla and her three
daughters at their funeral today for
white caskets were brought before the
altar and mourners spread out in the
pews in accordance with physical
distancing guidelines she was an
elementary school teacher and her girls
were aged six four and one the service
was closed to the public because of
kovat 19 restrictions but warned
mourners were able to watch a live
stream and audio of the service was
played outside the church in Nova Scotia
the remains of four Canadian armed
versus members killed when their
helicopter went down were returned to
their hometowns the RCMP escorted the
motorcade near Halifax today all six on
board and military cyclone helicopter
were killed when it went down off the
coast of Greece in April
captain Brendan McDonald captain Maxine
Nero more a master corporal Matthew
cousins and sub left tenant Matthew Pike
were all from Nova Scotia captain Kevin
Hagen's homecoming will be held this
Saturday in victoria bc and sub
leftenant abigail Cobras remains
returned to Canada in May the cause of
the crash is still under investigation
a Calgary toddler in a holding pattern
coming up will have to wait months for
an important surgery plus the new NHL
arena with an aim and goal unlike any
other
the federal government unveiled a new
program today part of its nine billion
dollar plan to help young people many of
whom are struggling to find summer jobs
in the midst of this pandemic
post-secondary students and recent
graduates who want to volunteer to help
their communities recover can now apply
for newly created service opportunities
they're posted online through the
government's I want to help website
which includes a list of local
organizations there will be compensation
for the volunteer work students and
graduates can earn $1,000 for every 100
hours worked with a cap set at five
thousand dollars or five hundred hours
well we know young people and children
are much less likely to get seriously
ill from coping 19 and people who are
over the age of 60 but our kids are
still paying a price in other ways
especially those who are waiting for
surgery tonight Heather Eurex West looks
at the indirect harm kovat 19 is having
on Canadian children two-year-old nash
rickey is waiting for surgery and
because of Ko fit 19 you'll likely be
waiting for some time I called to do a
checkup and they said it might actually
be another nine months in addition to
the time we've already waited the
Calgary toddler was born with a health
condition the longer he waits to have it
corrected the higher his chances of
developing health problems down the road
but the pandemic has created backlogs in
surgery just one of many indirect
impacts the virus is having on
children's health severe illness and
hospital admissions Reuters at over 19
have been uncommon in children and
people yet they will experience
substantial indirect physical social and
mental health effects waited pandemic in
an analysis published in this week's
Canadian Medical Association Journal dr.
Peter Gill and co-authors take a look at
what we know so far for one hospital
visits by children are down in the UK
Ireland and Italy pediatric admissions
to emergency departments fell by 75%
during lockdown periods in Canada sick
kids hospital in Toronto reported 30%
fewer children in the emergency room in
March and 62% fewer kids in April
compared to last year and while that may
be because fewer kids are getting sick
or injured while at home
it may also be because parents are
choosing to delay care we want to
communicate the families that healthcare
is open we're available we've modified
our health system to be safe and
certainly if you're worried about your
child you should seek care there is also
evidence childhood vaccine schedules are
being interrupted in May the World
Health Organization estimated 80 million
children have had vaccinations canceled
or delayed but the concerns extend
beyond children's physical health social
isolation protocols are having an impact
on their mental and emotional well-being
two researchers say many of these
impacts could lead to long-term health
concerns I'm scared for him for Miranda
Ritchie there is real concern that her
son will feel the impact of this
pandemic long after the virus is no
longer a threat
Heather Eric's West Global News Calgary
I had the rare find that made a minor
Tanzania's newest millionaire
you are watching global national the
world's largest online retailer Amazon
has bought the naming rights to the
future home of Seattle's new NHL
franchise CEO Jeff Bezos plans to call
it climate pledge Arena and says it will
be the first Net Zero Carbon certified
arena in the world recycle bins will
replace garbage cans and reclaimed
rainwater will be used to create what
could be the greenest ice in the NHL
Amazon which has been criticized for not
doing enough to combat climate change
didn't disclose how much it's paying for
the rights the venue in downtown Seattle
is undergoing a major renovation to
accommodate the new franchise team set
to begin play next year voting is
underway in Russia that could reset the
clock and keep President Vladimir Putin
in office until 2036 the seven day vote
was meant to start on July 1st but
authorities opened polling stations a
week ahead of schedule they say it's to
stop overcrowding during the pandemic
critics say Putin has been in power far
too long and fear the vote will mean
he'll stay there much longer it could
allow him to run for two more
back-to-back six-year terms the
Democratic Republic of Congo has
declared its deadliest Ebola outbreak
over the outbreak began in August 2018
and it killed more than 2,000 people it
was the world's second largest Ebola
outbreak on record and the 10th to hit
the DRC since 1976 the Health Minister
says it was the longest most complex and
deadliest fight in the Central African
nations history a small-scale miner from
Tanzania is celebrating a big discovery
he is now a millionaire after finding
the world's largest ever tanzanite
stones some of the rarest gemstones on
earth he earned over three million
dollars for the two tanzanite stones
which can only be found in a tiny area
in the country's north they are the
largest ever to be found they weight 9.2
and 5.8 kilograms each the man who is 52
years old sold the stones to the
country's mining ministry and says he'll
use the money to build a shopping mall
in school for his community and a whole
one big party when life gives you bad
grapes what do you make next the good
solution from BC
this stunning time-lapse video shows a
decade in the life of our son every
second is one day NASA's Solar Dynamics
Observatory released this to mark a
decade of its work it's gathered more
than 400 million high-resolution images
of the Sun and it's and they will
countless new discoveries about the
workings of our closest star and how it
influences the solar system nASA has
announced its naming its headquarters in
Washington DC after Mary W Jackson in
1958 she became NASA's first black
female engineer and played a pivotal
role in helping American astronauts
reach space she was also one of NASA's
hidden figures made famous in the
Hollywood movie NASA says the name
change is a reminder the Mary Jackson is
one of the many incredible and talented
professionals in NASA's history who
contributed to the agency's success with
the pandemic looming so large in our
lives it's easy to forget the threat
wildfires have posed to Canadians in the
past in 2018 DC had its worst fire
season on record more than a million
hectares of land was on fire including
some vineyards the smoke created a
crisis or so the winemakers thought
Robin Gill explains in 2018 the flames
were looming large over BC's Okanagan
Valley one of the worst fire seasons on
record it was frightening for winery
owners whose businesses were in danger
most escaped severe damage but going
into harvest season they knew that some
of their grapes had been tinged with
smoke at Vanessa vineyard it wouldn't be
until the wine was actually in the
bottles and tested by the team that they
knew it wasn't up to standard we could
had poured it down the drain apart would
have been the cheapest and easiest for
us to do but you know when I heard that
you know the Corvette hit and the that
we could make good use of it Vanessa
vineyard teamed up with a distillery and
brewed close to 600 litres of wine
valued at $35,000 into hand sanitizer
farmers are always at the mercy of
Mother Nature and when the temperatures
rise they have to keep an eye out for
fire season the trick or trouble with
with smoke paint
is that it doesn't necessarily show up
when you're verifying when you're making
the wine so you're never really too sure
until really it's in the bottle or when
you're bottling three that force
wineries to get creative this is the
bottle what we affectionately refer to
mold to main water it's Patrick winery
mulled over some ideas and well came up
with mulled wine for this coming
Christmas you just have to get creative
and you know mother nature dictates what
we do you know at the end were farmers
and we got to adjust accordingly adjust
and acclimate Vanessa vineyard maybe
taking a loss on the wine but the new
product is headed to homeless shelters
as my mom says is ninety-six you know
what these are the times that you do
things that you help people that need it
the most
these are indeed those times and a
pairing of ideas can produce some good
notes
Robin Gill Global News Vancouver and
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen we leave you
tonight with a Canadian band playing
catch-up ahead of Canada Day walk off
the earth is covering the song o Canada
with bottles of ketchup using a Canadian
condiment the band is adding two virtual
Canada Day celebrations with a saucy
little anthem thanks for watching
Robin Gill will be here tomorrow and
I'll see you on Sunday for the new
reality take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
oh nice try
yawns expire
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay
please
[Music]